vanessa's in atlanta georgia hi vanessa
how are you
hey jay before i get started i just
wanted to thank you
for what you do my parents were able to
change our family lineage and became the
first millionaires in their family
because of you
wow i'm proud of them they're heroes
that's awesome
yeah very cool i i have a question
and please don't yell at me but um
i have never been in debt i never want
to be in debt
i'm thankful for that i'm a full-time
college student
graduate student and i work part-time in
customer service
um with joe biden's ten thousand dollar
student loan forgiveness and with the
fact that they're not expecting payments
on
interest on student loans um until the
pandemic is over
well currently until december 31st i was
wondering is it
financially responsible and morally
ethical for me to take out
ten thousand dollars that i don't need
it's going to be forgiven and i don't
have to pay interest or payments on it
well let me just tell you another that
is not a law
that is his wish and he's not the
president yet
yeah i'm only 20 confident in him yeah
well
and he has to get that through congress
which has in the senate what are known
as republicans
the chances of that passing are really
close to zero
so you don't take out a loan on what you
might think some freaking politicians
are gonna do
yeah and you said you want to take out
ten thousand dollars you don't need
did i hear you say that well my goodness
well that's the problem i mean i'm gonna
be real straightforward with you
should you take out ten thousand dollars
as a government loophole
i mean this is the kind of policy stuff
we're talking about it's a mirage
and it's got you thinking in a way
that's you would not normally think
well let me take advantage of this
loophole and take out ten thousand
dollars
i don't need i just think that this
is uh yeah no the answer is no i'm i'm
i'm i'm at a loss to be honest with you
yeah the answer is no well
this is what this is what this is
polyamory
but it takes a perfectly normal person
who had a plan yeah
and then politicians promising uh we're
gonna send you money
makes them think in abnormal ways and so
yeah it's uh
this is the problem with stupid butt
stuff they're always strings attached to
that stuff even if they got a version of
that past
there are strings always attached you
cannot do it by executive order no he
can't he can't get through congress no
so it's one more time it's like oprah
you get a car and you get a car and you
get a car and i've gotten elected and
i'm gonna give you this and i'm gonna
give you that and it's
horse crap everything's free except it's
not
yeah it's not and when i was a kid
growing up
they used to say if something was
difficult they would say
well that'll take an act of congress
remember that of course
absolutely translation getting something
through an act of congress
is very difficult yes very difficult
just for those of you who are sitting
around thinking that the government is
getting ready to give you money
or that the potential new president is
going to give you money
it takes an act of congress which is a
saying
that indicates something is difficult
because an act of congress is
difficult and uh with a republican
senate very doubtful yeah
to say the least and remember this just
a
just a psa public service announcement
for everybody the government cannot
thrive it cannot grow absent of your
tax dollars your money so we look at the
freddie may you know the whole federal
student loan program when that was
brought up
that was the idea that that college
education was becoming this big thing in
this new way of becoming successful they
thought well we'll subsidize it
but we're going to charge the american
people and it started off with grants
and then it became a big blown up
student loan program and they thrive
with higher interest rates than
than private loans and that's how that
all kind of gets started so we have to
understand that when government offers
something
they always want something back because
they cannot thrive they don't produce
anything
they do not they live off of your money
they are
parasites yeah that's repairs you have
to understand that relationship
they don't there's no free gifts from
the almighty government
yeah and here's another clue okay
regardless of
whether that fleshed out to be exactly
true which i do believe to be true
but i'm 60 years old
100 of the people that i know who have
waited on someone in government in the
white house
in the senate to fix their lives 100
of them their lives suck still waiting
because they're still waiting on someone
else to fix their life and so
boys and girls ladies and gentlemen it
is your job to fix your life
that's why when she said thank you for
my parents becoming millionaires
following your stuff
i said they're heroes they it was their
job i did not give them any money
and i appreciate the thank you but i
didn't give them any money they didn't
become millionaires because of me they
became millionaires because i showed
them how to do
something but they that's the easy part
the hard part is actually going and
doing it that's right so
when you go and do something that's when
we call you a
doer not a victim not a dreamer
okay back to breathing again